E aí
um Ok eu tenho calma eu não quero que
ninguém vai embora
por favor permaneçam sentados
queria começar por desmontar um carinho
da
da minha história e peço que não se ri a
partida seriam à partida
Eu Nasci Há 34 anos atrás tem espinho
Vivo também espinho mas os 12 primeiros
anos da minha vida foi proibido aqui na
no Concelho da Feira
aos 15 anos eu comecei a fazer Bodyboard
que ainda hoje me desporto de eleição e
que teve grande influência na minha vida
porque ainda hoje a minha o profissional
e ele quer uns para nós temos atrair o
curso de Juiz da Federação Portuguesa de
surf então ainda trabalho está ligada à
modalidade
e depois ainda 998 eu entrei na
faculdade e eles é a minha recursos
humanos e em 2001 comecei a trabalhar
aqui também na feira que me levou
Salvador nas piscinas municipais já em
Depois deixa só vou dizer que eu fui
trabalhar para os filhos municipais são
também da feira porque eu queria
arranjar dinheiro para isso papai nesse
agora o mês coisa que depois veio a
verificar-se que já depois em 2003
quando acabei meu curso eu tive a
oportunidade de ter um estágio na
empresa municipal feira viva na minha
área Que recursos humanos
eentão Fiquem lá até 2008 autor tive
mais uma oportunidade para chefiar e
liderar um departamento de recursos
humanos no grupo de empresas em Oliveira
de azeméis com uma uma dimensão superior
e então agarrei a oportunidade aquelas
duas fotos no canto superior esquerdo
são também no projeto musical que ele
tem também corridas aqui na feira a a
foto ali do Meio Foi mesmo que nada aqui
ó pele naquela casa ali embaixo
e aquela foto ali à direita no canto
superior direito é uma foto para mim
especial porque eu sempre que preciso de
me animar basicamente para o telemóvel
Não tem aquela foto e porque não há
maneira de olhar para ela fazem não
partir a rir e assim e basicamente fico
mais animado então
começando desculpa para ela eu então não
passado eu tive a oportunidade de criar
um projeto e consequente a minha empresa
que se chama manda aquele primeiro slide
que é uma plataforma online que aposta
na publicação de conteúdos na área do
desenvolvimento pessoal e profissional
o e pronto o manda ter Mais
especificamente a área do emprego da
formação e também do empreendedorismo
com cerca de um ano e meio a plataforma
conseguiu
cerca de 150 mil seguidores nas várias
redes sociais Onde está presente e o
site manda.com pelo site do projeto
conta com cerca de meio milhão de
visualizações por mês
esta exposição do projeto é um ano
passado também com a ajuda e também deve
dizer que tem alguma sorte mas com ajuda
também da exposição a alguns Miria
objeto é bom então essa exposição e já
durante e já durante este ano fui
convidado para falar da minha
experiência e também contar um Tang
ações do projeto em alguns seminários de
empreendedorismo e não desse seminário
de empreendedorismo em que a plateia era
na sua maior parte composta por
estudantes que vinham do secundário
as pessoas uma das professoras que
estava a acompanhar fiz uma questão ela
ela estava me dizer que tendo em conta
que os alunos ela estava numa fase muito
importante as suas vidas pois era uma
fase em que tinham que a fazer obras
importantes como escolher a áreas a
seguir etc e tendo em conta
o desemprego e desigualdade no mercado
emprego presente qual seria o conselho
que eu lhe daria não ter a primeira
coisa que me veio à cabeça basicamente
foi óleo Eu Na minha opinião eu diria
para fazer aquilo que gostam porque
todos nós sabemos à partida que quem tem
a oportunidade de fazer aquilo que gosta
tem em termos relativos maiores ou
melhores qualidades uma mais hipóteses
de conseguir ser bem sucedido
bom então nós falamos mais um pouquinho
sobre aquilo e eu quando sair daquele
senhor acho que ia sair com um ano com a
impressão que é que não tinha explicado
assim muito bem e por quê Porque em boa
verdade será correto nós dizemos que
quem tem alguém consegue se e a sua
paixão terá eventualmente melhores
hipóteses de serviço social das melhor
agora dizer alguém que te pergunta
diretamente olha como é que eu faço para
ter certeza e tu respondes olhos do para
ter sucesso cegos a tua paixão isso eu
já não acho que possa ser considerado um
conselho Vale do vão precisar Só isto
por duas razões primeiro das quais a
maior parte das pessoas não sabe qual é
sua paixão e isso um lugar a maior parte
das pessoas pensa que sabe qual é a sua
paixão música da minha também Descobri
que não era bem assim
e então de tudo aquilo que eu tenho
pesquisado lido experienciado e também
assistido nas pessoas a minha volta é
que neste âmbito a Esse é um resultado a
paixão é é um é uma energia e aquilo que
ele vem quando nós fazemos a fazer a
mente aquilo que gostamos não seja
fazemos aquilo que vai de encontro com
os nossos valores e vai se encontra em
relação aquilo que que nós acreditamos
ou seja vai ser esta energia que
efetivamente nos da vontade de acordar
de manhã para ir fazer a fazer aquilo
que gostamos né Vamos aquela excitação
de quando estamos a caminho de fazer
aquilo que gostamos e também aquela
situação como Aquela vamos fazer
basicamente eu acho que paixão é quando
nós dizemos hoje eu até fazia isto de
graça mas eu não sou a pagar por cima né
e pronto deixe-me só
seguir aqui continuando aqui a falar um
bocadinho sobre sobre acesso Todos nós
sabemos que e deixa-me só fazer voltar
de um bocadinho atrás que no meu caso e
surgiu um cadinho de forma natural tendo
em conta na falar um pouquinho sobre
humana surgiu o máximo que a gente forma
natural porque há 2 anos atrás e eu
fiquei desempregado porque a empresa na
qual trabalhava ter um processo de
insolvência e puxou então eu pela
primeira vez ainda essas da minha vida
vimos em trabalho e
por mais que a gente possa estar
preparado uma realidade dessas nunca
tendo estado numa situação daquelas
causa sempre algum desconforto
então de casa eu já gostaria de pedir já
gostava de escrever sobre liderança só
motivação aí sobre as outras temáticas
da minha área foi um bocadinho natural
para mim começar a fazer aquilo que eu
já gostava mas tentei com a fazer de
forma metódica a e tive a sorte de
passar alguns dias ter bons resultados
Mas falando aqui um bocadinho sobre
sucesso Todos nós sabemos à partida que
hoje em dia para termos sucesso
em qualquer área ou em qualquer coisa
que façamos no mínimo temos que ser bons
mas eu acho que nós estamos a chegar a
um ponto nos termos em que vai ser bom
Tecnicamente não chega eu acho que para
Além disso é muito importante a forma
como nós nos relacionamos com nós
comunicamos com os nossos clientes e
custo fazer nossa volta e por isso é que
também hoje em dia se fala muito mas só
que ouvir tudo o que tenha a ver com o
relacionamento interpessoal etc e neste
ano e que eu acho que hoje em dia
vivemos tempos extraordinários e é assim
e muito por culpa da forma como nós e
posso se calhar dizer todos aqui
presentes uma forma que nós todos aqui
presentes nos relacionamos e comunicamos
online e agora estou especificamente a
falar das redes sociais porque se calhar
nós há dez anos atrás eu só falei isso
também no âmbito de quem quer a criar um
projeto novo ou algo do gênero se não há
dez anos atrás
falávamos do marketing colocar como
sendo o melhor marketing mas não era
suficiente porque era pouco alavancado
era lento limitado por nós que só com a
mensagem a poucas pessoas antigamente
Hoje em Dia com as redes sociais nós
temos o marketing boca-a-boca levado e
ela arrancar a um extremo porque nós
temos viram restaurante ou qualquer
coisa do gênero que estamos gostar do
prato é bonito o atendimento fogão nós
temos alguma foto e postamos logo para
centenas de amigos nossos ver o problema
é que isto
também funciona quer para bom funciona
cartão mal por isso é que eu acho que
também é uma coisa positiva que está a
acontecer hoje em dia que é parece o
Chico espertismo está a perder o seu
espaço e parece que o ser vão E ser
honesto está voltar a ser a moda eu acho
que é muito bom e acho que tem que era
desta nesta muito que é um projeto é
algo que tem que ser aproveitado
um simples mais fácil queria trazer um
debate assim um bocadinho a propósito
explicar muitas pessoas chegam ao pé de
mim e que me perguntam
basicamente assim olha eu gostava ter
objetivo por isso que eu não igual mas
depois disso o teu mas diz-me lá como é
que eu consigo fazer isso de forma fácil
eu tenho constatado é que a maior parte
destas pessoas e não são poucas
acreditem que sebo às vezes até recebo
e-mails com com essas coisas
e a maior parte dessas pessoas acredita
que atalhos para conseguir fazer coisa
outras para o sucesso e nos tô aqui
dizer que eu sou muito mais por sair
agora para trabalhar às vezes acreditam
que há atalhos
e naturalmente a minha resposta para
para essas pessoas divisória único
detalhe que eu conheço para para
conseguir fazer as coisas ou bem ou mal
é um trabalho é o trabalho vou fazer a
fazer por isso é que existe também
aquela frase que
sucesso ou trabalho é um por cento de
inspiração e noventa e nove porcento de
transpiração mas não é só quando nós
temos o nosso próprio projeto ou a nossa
própria empresa isso também alcalina
está aprender porque tem uma empresa há
pouco mais de um ano
temos que ser muito resilientes porque a
volta e meia a realidade vem e estamos
assim os outros Valentes no estômago
porque lá está nós podemos até três ou
quatro dias bons mas no quinto a
realidade vem e prima né assim eu
acredito que esteja
comum a qualquer pessoa que tenha só pra
ver peso rápido e pode ser diferente
pode vir não sei Dias podem ser menos o
podem ser anos mas a verdade é que
últimos a gente também Pergunta a tu
trabalhaste perguntas eu tenho tantos
anos a empresa é do chefe do teu chefe é
é é muito fixe não é e diga pa sentem
coisas tem coisas boas e coisas mas tem
coisas melhores e coisas piores é como
tudo
Ah e por isso é que eu acho que desculpa
mais uma vez ali o planeamento seus
objetivos são coisas muito importantes e
Deixem que vos diga em primeiro lugar e
agora peço-vos que estejam muito atentos
porque esta será eventualmente a coisa
mais inteligente que eu fazer
na minha gravação que é
não há limite para a preguiça humana não
há nada como o da glande e o prazo que é
para nós ir contra mim fauna para nos
fazer dar corda aos sapatos e fazer as
coisas e outra coisa é nós todos temos
um bocadinho daquilo que eu gosto de
chamar uma relatividade espaço ao
temporal que faz-nos pensar que tudo que
esteja longe de nós quer em termos de
espaço quer em termos de tempo as
pessoas que nos afeta às vezes é que nós
ajustamos avental smala desabou de um
edifício na Índia morreram 10 pessoas
mas depois temos pena morreram todos
morreram mais uns quantos temos pena mas
essa relatividade que nos atinge em
termos do tempo
Olá
tudo que seja a médio e longo prazo mas
Acabámos por delegar para segundo plano
e é várias empresas como que eu tenho
que trabalhar também a nível do coaching
assistiu essa realidade Porque tudo que
estava em
média a longo prazo mas sempre podemos
buscar com a barriga para frente e
quando estamos mais lá frente vamos ter
problemas e é um bocadinho aquele
conceito de com a nós estamos sempre a
apagar fogos e não temos tempo a mais
nada nunca vamos ter tempo a criar
procedimentos ou formas de Deus Poder
prevenir
o
OK mas o mesmo
e no último eu queria também queríamos
falar um tempinho dá um processo de
criatividade e também no processo de
produtividade isso também por
pelo facto de algumas pessoas me
abordarem um sentido Estas pessoas que
realmente querem criar um projeto novo
ou por estarem desempregados têm sentem
aquela vontade de ter a sua própria
sua próprio negócio o seu próprio
projeto E muitas não sabem como começar
e às vezes ela até queria começar uma
coisa novas aí rapaz não tenho ideias
como é que como é que eu faço
eu essas pessoas eu respondo muito
basicamente isto que é não ficar à
espera de saber exatamente Quem és para
começar a fazer algo por é exatamente a
fazer coisas a trabalhar o hora agora
outras coisas exatamente a fazer nós
vamos cobrir com insumos e
descobrir as coisas coisas que ajudam
também de fazer aquilo que gostamos
quando descobrir aquilo que gostamos
é mas não é só isso
eventualmente
até nos tempos Eu andei à procura andava
à procura de toda a pesquisar os
conceitos criatividade para tirar
eventualmente às vezes escrevo artigos
no meio também sobre as diferenças olhos
e dei de caras com um artigo que tinha
umas dicas de criatividade e
esportividade do Jerry seinfeld aquele
comediante que a nossa amizade começou
bem
o Jerry seinfeld ainda hoje depois de
ser feito aquela série atividade dele
intensiva é ser comediante stand-up não
corre brilhantes base a fazer ver o
tempo ele corre brilhantes bares a fazer
despertar questão da Então eu tenho uma
regra muito específica e muito metódica
para conseguir ser produtivo e criativo
e consegui escrever milhares de piadas e
muito basicamente ele e também muito
simples ele tem um calendário na parede
sua casa em que cada dia do local é um
quadradinho Que preencha cada via que
trabalha e se sente para tentar escrever
ou seja sempre não q60s culpa
que se senta para para escrever e para
tentar fazer as suas piadas
o objetivo último Será que ele não
quebre aquela linha de cozinhas
preenchidas ou seja na criatividade
também é muito assim é é o apareceu para
trabalhar também a uma frase que diz
noventa porcento sucesso disse isso
joinha até aparecer para trabalhar não
aqui fórmulas mágicas e por isso é que a
palavras do plenamente o planeamento é
assim importante temos que ter os nós
nossas atitudes nossos procedimentos nos
suplementos eventualmente feitos agora o
mais importante a minha frente Vou fazer
a fazer porque assim quando nós
começamos um plano nosso plano até
chegar ao fim vai sofrer muitas
modificações vamos de ter várias disse
os condicionalismos
nós somos uma coisa nova estamos no
ponto de partida o mais natural é não
consigo ver o quando chegar a por isso o
máximo que nós podemos fazer é
monistas dos melhores das melhores
competências reunimos As melhores
pessoas os melhores recursos mas haverá
sempre um grau de incerteza em relação
aquilo que em relação aos desafios a que
nos propomos
os estudos vamos fazer por isso quando
perguntam em relação ao como começar a
em volta um bocadinho início a tentar
perceber o porquê que nós gostamos de
fazer aquilo que fazemos por quê que
sentimos aquela energia quando zero
naquela situação porque eu acho que se
verdadeiramente a gente sentir aquela
energia e aquela entusiasmo nós vamos
conseguir passar as outras pessoas
através do nosso trabalho muito obrigado
E aí